[Musique]
avec nico l'artiste notre coach et
formatrice qui est avec nous alors déjà
au départ on va préciser quand même que
chacun éduquer son enfant comme il
l'entend on ne sera peut-être pas
d'accord forcément avec vous surtout
néanmoins on doit vous m'arrêtez si je
me trompe
le renseigner on va dire la valeur des
choses donc de l'argent ça va peut-être
en tout cas nécessitait un temps
d'échangé et de transactions entre les
parents que nous sommes et entre
l'enfant et ça c'est plutôt pas mal
madame la formatrice watch
oui c'est extrêmement important
effectivement d'envisager que ce qui va
permettre à l'enfant de grandir et
d'avoir une bonne représentation du
désir c'était dur j'ai tout acheté c'est
tout bouge je veux aller au ciné et c
est la réalité de est ce que mon
portefeuille me le permet la transaction
s'est vraiment prendre du temps avec
l'enfant pour lui expliquer comment ça
va fonctionner ce qui est d'ailleurs
très différent d'une famille à l'autre
alors avant de décider sur nous donne de
l'argent ou pas finalement à ses enfants
voici quelques pistes pour y voir plus
clair et après nous répondons
concrètement à toutes les questions que
vous vous posez sur l'argent de poche
monfils qui a 7 ans me réclame de
l'argent de poche donne nuit ça lui
apprendra à compter en france l'argent
de poche à la cote
trois jeunes sur quatre à partir de 6
ans au reçoivent et les parents français
sont les plus généreux en europe juste
après les italiens 2 euros par semaine
avant 5 ans 5 euros entre 5 et 10 ans 10
euros entre 10 et 15 ans et 20 euros
après 15 ans pour beaucoup d'entre nous
largue en poche et pour l'enfant un
excellent moyen de responsabiliser
d'apprendre à gérer un budget et de
devenir plus autonome
on peut commencer dès qu'il s'est bien
comptés vers 6 ou 7 ans
mais attention à ce que ce petit pécule
ne soit pas soumis à des obligations de
résultats scolaires de tâches ménagères
ou autres affreuse conditions parents
n'abusez pas du chantage à l'argent de
poche et laisser l'enfant l'utiliser en
toute liberté
les erreurs font partie de
l'apprentissage tant pis il s'achète un
jouet nul il fera plus attention la
prochaine fois
à partir de 12 ans au peu les initier à
l'argent dématérialisée avec des cartes
bancaire rechargeable
il peut faire des retraites plafonné et
payés avec les banques proposent aussi
des comptes pour les 12-17 haut avec on
se détend un contrôle parental
les bons comptes forme les bons petits
j'ai une brochette de maman sur ce
plateau je ne résiste pas à l'envié de
vous demandez vous muriel archos qui est
la maman de ruben et victoria votre
propre expérience je vous ai vu sourire
vous faites comment pour ruben et
victoria alors j'en ai une qui est une
fourmi donc ça qui est grandement quoi
ça mais c'est tout j'ai une cigale qui
s'appelle ruben est en fait en fait je
fais très clairement la sonarges un
pistolet mois effectivement si au bout
et au 15 du mois n'y a plus rien c'est
au choix ou espace de sortie ou alors
des petits travaux d'intérêts généraux
pour la maison donc c'est tu veux tu
veuilles au cinéma ok mais tu vas faire
quelque chose pour la maison et ça
fonctionne super bien comme ça saissac
et dingo un finalement avant d'avoir
votre propre expérience avec le tout
jeune harry
je vais venir vers vous autre maman que
vous êtes virginie mais je me tourne
vers vous nicole la formatrice et la
coach vous avez entendu ce que vient de
dire elle a deux enfants
visiblement c'est la même éducation mais
il ya deux réactions totalement
différente est ça veut dire qu'il n'y a
pas vraiment de règle est que chaque
enfant dans une fratrie pour agir
différemment
c'est en ça que justement vous lui
disiez tout à l'heure le fait de parler
avec l'enfant et de transaxio n'est en
fait va faire que des enfants vont
préférer que les parents leur fasse
plaisir en achetant à leurs côtés bien
tiens je trouve ça joli etc
ben oui en fait oui c'est bien je te
l'offre et autres et d'autres enfants
vraiment souhaitent être autonomes et je
pense que justement c'est bien de faire
des différences
vous parlez sous contrôle d'une maman
tout jeune bébé je veux rien n'est
encore bébé arrière oui il n'a pas
encore deux ans oui alors justement où
il voulait les affaires qu'on manque
comment vous pouvez d'ailleurs plus tard
vous je me suis pas posé la question
j'avoue qu'il ya une chose dans le petit
sujet moi qui me fais régions je me dis
mais ça c'est ça me paraît une bêtise je
voudrais bien votre avis nicole c'est la
carte bleue à nos martyrs de zouzou
vouloir faire de façon dématérialisée
absente pas avait sérieusement je pense
que l'un des grands grand intérêt
effectivement de l'argent de poche c'est
de permettre effectivement à l'enfant
d'avoir une représentation matérialiser
il faut savoir que pour les enfants
enfin tout ce qui est virtuel c'est à
dire qu'on imagine c'est compliqué un
temps qu'ils ont pas un certain âge donc
avoir l'argent compter dans le porte
monnaie quand ils savent compter et
c'est savoir qu'avec quatre rouges peux
m'acheter ça c'est important
moi aussi je suis pas du tout d'accord à
part à partir d'un certain âge bien sûr
avec la carte bleue je trouve ça triste
effectivement de les faire déjà rentré
dans cette consommation abstraite à la
une autre maman qui a envie de vous
poser une question au 0 805 383 383 on
va vous écouter s'il vous plaît la
question de l'argent poste s'est posé à
ses taux après beaucoup de réflexion on
a décidé de mettre en place à l'entrée
de son cp c'est un euro par année d'âge
chaque mois c'est à dire que quand elle
avait 6 ans tous les mois recevait 6
euros et maintenant qu'elle a 13 ans et
reçoit 13 euros par mois
comment va faire quand elle
être un petit peu plus grande au lycée
ou adolescentes parce que 18 euros à la
18 ans j'ai peur que ce soit un petit
peu juste quand même bain où on se pose
la question si vous vous avez des
astuces à nous donner à ce moment là on
est d'accord merci espère en tout cas on
a peut-être quelques éléments de réponse
nicole vous en pensez-quoi en augmente
l'argent au fur et à mesure que les
bougies se rajoute sur le gâteau d'année
oui on augmente mais peut-être pas un
euro fin chacun choisit en plus selon
son budget parce que les fermes sont
toutes différentes mais moi je suis très
très partante de ce qui était nommé tout
à l'heure par muret sur sur l'intérêt
général je pense que c'est extrêmement
important qu'est ce que vous appelez
l'intérêt général supérieur délit
d'achat quelque chose l'intéressé pas
parler l'intérêt de la famille voilà et
c'est ça l'intérêt général c'est bien
qu'il ya un système c'est une famille et
montrer aux enfants que dans les
systèmes en fait on peut faire des
choses pour le système s'est vraiment
les préparer à s'adapter demain et je
trouve que justement pour répondre à la
dame
ce qui peut peut-être se passer parce
qu'elle le dit bien quand l'enfant
grandit à 18 ans 18 euros ça peut faire
très juste peut-être effectivement
envisagé de rené gossip par rapport à la
réalité des besoins et de ce qui peut
être mis en place en termes d'intérêt
général pour la famille il ya très peu
de papa qui se sont posé la question il
ya beaucoup de mamans qui ont réagi au 0
800 480 places et une maman de quatre
enfants qui a la parole
annabelle ça se passe comment chez vous
racontez nous alors chez nous il n'ya
pas d'argent en poche
nous privilégions la récompense par de
l'argent pour des travaux effectués
ponctuellement à la maison ou à
l'extérieur
je trouve que c'est bénéfique à ça leur
apprend bien sûr la valeur de l'argent
ça ne prend pas du ciel et en plus ils
le dépensent moins volontiers ayant eu
plus de difficultés à le gagner
alors j'avais une question à ce sujet
d'ailleurs y at il une réelle différence
entre la façon de faire des familles des
villes et famille des campagnes merci
je suis pas si on peut parler de famille
des villes famille les campagnes mais en
tout cas merci annabelle d'abord chez
cette maman qu'on si j'ai bien compris
il faut gagner gagner pardon son argent
de poche en effectuant des petits
travaux c'est un petit peu comme chez
noria et vous vous en pensez quoi parce
qu'on l'a vu tout à l'heure et les
enfants réagissent pas toujours pareil
c'est ça qui est rigolo dans une fratrie
ya le panier percé ya l'économie et la
fourmi
alors je pense qu'effectivement et
pourquoi pas je pense que quatre enfants
c'est pas évident non plus au niveau du
budget mais donner à l'enfant
enfin quelque chose qui est transaxio
nez et le lui donner c'est vraiment à
lui en fait et c'est à lui de voir
comment il va gérer cet argent
ça me paraît vraiment développé de
l'autonomie faire une relation cause à
effet entre tu fais un travail et à une
récompense c'est peut-être effectivement
empêcher l'enfant d'envisager que il
peut avoir une somme d'argent à gérer à
lui et que c'est lui qui mettra les
codes et les règles
alors écoutez une autre maman elle
s'appelle valérie 0 805 383 383 aussi
son témoignage
donc j'ai deux enfants une petite fille
de 4 ans et un garçon de 12 ans et pour
mon fils de 12 ans préfère lui donner en
fait ce dont il a besoin
sur le moment c'est à dire s'il a besoin
de fournitures scolaires de 100 plaisir
en achetant un magazine ou des bonbons
je préfère qu'ils nous demandent plutôt
que de donner 30 euros par mois par
exemple pour moi ça va leur donner de
l'argent de poche ça inquiète à la de la
surconsommation en fait
merci valérie alors pas de régularité on
va dire dans l'argent de poche c'est
aussi parfois une pratique
si j'osais je dirais que c'est un petit
peu comme au resto c'est à la carte
alors pas la carte bancaire des
compagnies fabriquer mais au moins c'est
ce qu'on pensait c'est à dire qu'en fait
j'entends que fin la dame envisage de
faire une réponse immédiate aux désirs
de l'enfant si elle estime que c'est
bien donc là il se passe j'ai envie et
j'ai pas en quoi je trouve quand même
que l'argent de poche est quelque chose
qui développe chez l'enfant la capacité
à anticiper c'est que c'est lui qui a
cette somme d'argent et qui va se
confronter aux cadres de réalité
2 si j'ai envie d'aller au cinéma je ne
peux pas m'acheter tel magazine voilà
bien que si on donne de l'argent de
poche
on ne doit pas intervenir sur comment il
doit le départ seulement alors l'annoncé
du nom du tout soyons clairs il a une
somme et cette somme effectivement
dépendre de sa manière à lui est
d'acheter c'était très bien et
d'ailleurs dans le reportage à propos du
jouet bidon s'il a envie de s'acheter un
joueur ridicule un portable qui coûtent
une fortune mais il a l'argent même si
ça peut nous énerver il faut le laisser
faire oui et alors un tout petit conseil
aussi parce que c'est des choses qu'on
rencontre lorsqu'on a affaire à des
enfants dépensiers c'est à dire que ils
ne se rendent pas compte de la valeur en
fait à ce qu'on peut faire pour éviter
des vrais frustration c'est que ont
négocié une somme par mois et on l'a
fractionne hebdomadaire c'est à dire que
il sait que dans la semaine
il dispose de temps parce que à 12 ans
on a du mal à imaginer au bout de quatre
semaines est ce que j'ai encore des
soucoupes à malines parce que je parle à
des enfants jusqu'à 12 ans ont cette
fois c'est vous le savez avec moi j
avais grands parents qui sont aussi avec
nous c'est au moment de l'adolescence
que ça commence à ce compris saisissions
s'interdit coalition salou djibo muriel
caisse pour faire le bien c'est ça
dans ce cas la populaire je veux dire
c'est ce qu'on nous demande les enfants
qui viennent chez nous aujourd'hui parmi
toutes les choses demandées il ya cette
idée d'être populaire ça veut dire quoi
mais ça veut dire que c'est une période
les deux licences ou vous avez à la fois
besoin d'être regardée et en même temps
de vous écouter pour servir de quoi vous
avez besoin ça veut dire que s'il veut
le sweatshirt qu'à une certaine marque
meetic ou d'argent je prends les choses
c'est par exemple voilà on le laisse
l'acheter ah oui bien sûr à partir du
moment effectivement il va en apprendre
quelque chose
ne vous inquiétez pas ils achèteront ce
qui est drôlement un haut niveau des
vêtements
c'est à ça qu'ils nous renvoient des
yeux alors tambour battant dans le temps
bon dans tous les cas le plus important
pour nous finalement les parents c'est
toujours peut-être de justifier les
récompenses comme les punitions
financières et surtout je le redis
chaque cas est différent il faut pas
l'oublier
juste une petite chose importante on dit
pas aux enfants tu auras tu l argent si
tu réussis telle chose
parce que voyez l'école par exemple
c'est une obligation de réussir à
l'école on va pas négocier on négocie
pas ta la bonne note
tu as trois francs outre tous trois
euros non ces trois francs donc quelque
part si vous voulez on va négocier des
travaux qu'on fait pas d'habitude
vous voyez on enlever les feuilles dans
le jardin aider à débarrasser le garage
là on peut donner effectivement en plus
de l'argent de poche quand une enfant
est à sec
merci écoles pour toutes ces précisions
au revoir en replay sur france3 fr et
sur vos écrans connectés si vous